Having less than brilliant teeth doesn't have to mean a trip to the dentist or a whitening kit.
Try this all natural remedy instead.
You will need, baking soda, hydrogen peroxide, a small bowl, a toothbrush, and plastic wrap.
Optional, mint flavoring and cranberry juice.
Do not whiten teeth if you have cavities, open sores, gingivitis, or other gum disease.
Step one: In a small bowl, mix two teaspoons each of baking soda and hydrogen peroxide.
Stir until it is the consistency of regular toothpaste.
You may need to add a bit more peroxide.
Add a drop or two of sugar-free mint flavoring.
Step two: Apply the whitener to a toothbrush and use it as if it were regular toothpaste.
Leave the whitener on your teeth for at least two minutes.
Step three: Rinse thoroughly.
Do not swallow the whitener solution.
Try rinsing with cranberry juice to get rid of the whitener's taste.
It also kills bacteria.
Step four: Cover the bowl with a plastic wrap...
...and set the extra whitener aside for another use.
Step five. Brush with the peroxide paste no more than once a week.
Hydrogen peroxide can cause tissue damage if used too often.
Did you know, tooth enamel is the hardest tissue in the human body?